- I think about the things that
I know that you're going to do
that you think you're not.
And you don't think that
you're gonna be on Snapchat
and I know you're going to be.
So, one thing that I'm loving
right now is everybody and
Josh Elman I'm talking to you,
Gary discovered
Snapchat recently.
That's right I have turned
into a 13-year-old girl while
I've been away on vacation and
I am now a Snapchat queen.
I'm turning into a
14-year-old girl.
A lot of young entrepreneurs
asking me what advice I'd give
them and my answer is patience.
So all about this Snapchat.
I just, the attention.
I thought it'd be fun to put a
couple clips together from the
Chase Jarvis
interview I gave in 2013.
I would tell you if I'm a
photographer right now the
number one place
I would build an audience on,
number one is Snapchat.
Let me explain why.
The reality is is that Snapchat
is the one place that you can
almost guarantee consumption
because the picture disappears
people actually
click it and look at it
for those eight seconds.
Whereas in Twitter and Facebook,
you don't see everything.
You're just going
through too quickly.
Where in Snapchat you
actually give that photo,
oh by the way,
you give it those
7, 10, 11 seconds.
If I'm a photographer the
ability for me to take a photo
and then send it to my Snapchat
audience and actually have it
consumed and write on top
of it, unless you're a purist,
I get it.
- [Chase] No.
- But the truth is that
to me is a place where
they need to be
paying attention to.
And a little talk I gave
in Le Web as well.
- [Loic] Snapchat.
- Yeah, well, Snapchat--
- [Loic] Brands on Snapchat?
- Oh, absolutely.
I think, right now Snapchat
is one of the most successful
marketing tools for me
personally with my brand.
Everybody worries
about width, right?
Like everybody cares
about top line numbers.
Impressions, followers, people
care about dumb fucking data.
What Snapchat is doing
everybody is very simple,
it's not about how
many impressions you get.
It's how much attention you get.
I don't care what anybody in
this room does or watching at
home on live stream, the number
one thing we all have to do is
tell our story to
somebody along the path
of them making a decision.
Before you tell your story
you have to have somebody's
attention and what Snapchat does
is it gives you the attention.
Snapchat is a communication
funnel that for those nine
seconds while you're holding
it, you actually have to pay
attention which is
why it's important.
And once it evolves the way
Facebook evolved and becomes
older, there'll be an
opportunity for you
can you figure out how
to tell a story in an
eight second picture with
text over it that disappears.
This was me talking
about Snapchat in 2013.
This is not a 2016 phenomenon
for me and there's a little bit
of, yeah, let's
call it what it is.
I love the I told you so kind of
video and that's what this is.